how are you Ryan that's a great segue I
like that you know it's what I did a
reliever it's what I do for a living
right you know what I mean this is what
I do this is what I do that's all I'm
saying I'm gonna talk to you how you
guys doing I'm doing great
so these rule changes which one jumps
out at you say yes I'm so glad they're
doing this which one any of them no no
wow you know what I love I love the one
trade that attorney I think that's
awesome I think I think it adds a ton of
excitement I think it it asked teams to
ask who they are of themselves like
great away isn't from and you know
you're running a team it's like are we a
contender are we making a trade because
we can't wait another three to four
weeks to find out and get somebody off
the waiver wire
yeah the trade deadline will remain July
31st but the trade waivers were you
putting somebody on waivers somebody
claims them you take them back and you
make a trade with that person that's it
you put somebody on waivers now they can
just be claimed from now on that's the
rule you like that one yeah yeah I think
it I just think it I think it'll add
some more excitement to the July I
remember the trade deadline I used to
always just be not that it isn't so
exciting but there used to be some
massive blockbusters and some some
really big trades and I think the demand
for player is almost like a free agency
market because you knowing you can't get
them a month from now or anybody a month
from now is it big enough that you could
include somebody off waivers but you
can't make that trade anymore so I think
you see teams willing to part with guys
a lot a lot easier not easier a easier a
lot more than they they would likely if
they were still maybe a gamer too out of
the wild-card it's like wow we could set
our team up for the future by getting
rid of a certain player for for
prospects or a couple other ready
players so yeah it's excited I'm looking
forward to that yeah and then for 2020
this one is the one that's truly gonna
be the biggest change is there's a
maximum a minimum number of batters a
pitcher must face a minimum of three
batters unless the fewer than that takes
you to the end of an inning how do you
think that that will change the way
baseball is played managed executed Ryan
Dempster I don't know what is it it's a
change or is it reactivates of the way
it kind of used to be a little bit
you know that's what what happened guy
would come in and face three hitters and
get out of it and next thing you know
there would be now it's gone - a guy
comes in in the seventh he faces a
hitter another guy comes in after him
another guy comes in after him and the
inning takes thirty minutes you know
instead it's one two three and it takes
seven minutes and you're on to the next
guy because you know what that day he
was on and we don't even we're gonna
we're gonna see that happen I think
you're gonna see opportunities for guys
who never got to face guys I think
Kayson play will pick up I think you'll
see starting pitchers seeing the game a
little bit longer because if the
situation is I got a really really good
Max Scherzer going right now but it's
the eighth inning in a 1-1 game and I
got Bryce Harper on deck cool I'm just
going to just be careful with Bryce and
pitch and have them pitch to the other
guys because he's locked in against
every ready today
I just think that'll happen a little bit
more along the line and I think it's I
think it's a good thing yeah I'm sure
there's gonna be some analytics person
crunching the numbers saying somebody's
much better facing three three pit three
batters here and there and it'll still
be over analytics in a way but I'm all
for it you know and I don't mind pace of
play I don't mind it but I do kind of
mind you know one guy comes in for one
batter pop-up then another guy comes in
righty lefty righty lefty that's a
little bit much but other than that I
don't understand that the the although
I'm not privy to the research just the
absolute fixation on time of games that
seems to be going on right now will that
to hurry things up in between innings
that 25 fewer seconds in national
nationally televised games in between
innings five seconds and local games
it's all going to be now two minutes
uniform period two minutes in between
innings no matter it's on local or
national TV is that an issue Ryan um no
I I think people like you said the the
first time of play I think that's
baseball there is no there is no clock
you can't keep time that's the great
part about baseball the games never over
until that last out until whoever makes
that last out leaving the game that 27th
out or 35th out whatever it ends up
being that your
you're making the bottom half of that
ending or the top half that evening out
and I think it's pace of plays of the
issue and I think it helps pace of play
I think there's nothing better than when
I picture well I remember this when you
go out there and you're warm up and
you're ready to go and then you have to
wait to come back from commercial well
now listen you don't get back in that
flow and it's ball one it's ball two and
then you're getting into rhythm okay
here instead of a flow to the game and a
pace to the game and I think that's what
they're trying to do and I think you
know a lot of these rules are meant to
help with that and I think they will
help with that I think you know the
pitching changes sure maybe it not just
a minute or two off but it's more the
idea of the pace like some days I could
go through Barry Bonds Lance Berkman and
Jim Edmonds no problem and some days I
couldn't get through nephew Perez Craig
Counsell and you know the third-string
catcher I canti remembers number that's
the reality so I think pace of play will
pick up because guys will have that
opportunity to do that face a few
hitters and the game won't move I think
a little bit smoother well you know it
would help the game move a little bit
smoother or or better or in a more
fascinating fashion if that's the
concern is a few more singles doubles
and triples here it seems again you're
gonna walk together in singles doubles
and triples I hated the homer you know
what I mean well I I'm sure as a pitcher
but again it's a walk a strikeout or a
home run and in terms of a walk or a
strikeout you can have minutes on end
at-bats without a single ball put into
play Ryan and to me hammering at the
shift is what would change things and
I've been hammering it this literally
regular consumers of this show know I've
been tilting at this windmill for quite
some time and I'm a little disappointed
that the only way that I could see a
shift being affected will be after the
2020 season when this joint committee
that was announced today between
baseball and the Players Association to
just study other potential changes might
spit something out what is your take on
the shift Ryan oh man yeah I don't know
it's a tough one I understand I see it
it works but it still think that
homeruns go all the ballpark you know
hit I heard it from a lot of people and
they hit it over the shift and I'm not
super big on having a third
take run all the way over there and now
of a sudden I'm it's like a 5-3 but it
was really like a line drive to the
rightfielder but as a pitcher you're
trying to you're trying to defend your
team as a manager you're trying to put
those guys in the best position to the
numbers and maybe there's a recorrect
coming maybe it starts to become a thing
where guys start to do it there are guys
that do it there's guys that hit for
power that choke up and try to put the
ball the other way
there's the Joey Votto's the Anthony
Rizzo's the guys that do that with two
strikes show they get paid they get
taken care of and I think I would love
to just see the guys where they're at
and make the pitches but at the same
time I do understand the the prospects
of putting a shift on to better your
opponent's average but you know 0.15
because I was talking to Joe Maddon one
time and he's right and he said you know
sometimes baseball is the razor's edge
the laser's edge that's fine between
winning and losing you're trying to put
every advantage in your favor
interesting razor's edge lasers edge I
didn't heard that one before but that's
a Joe Maddon ISM I like it
hey Ryan thanks for the call we'll chat
with you as the season gets closer and
throughout the season really appreciate
it yeah that's right you bet that's ryan
dempster the MLB Network the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience